hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing now with the match
England versus Hikaru Nakamura and it's
quite the game I decided to skip game
for between Fabiano's and India but I
might show it tomorrow as I don't know
if I will have to my time tomorrow to
show some games so that's why kind of
why I overdid it today with the videos
but if I manage the time I will show
that one but as you all know Fabien
already won the match so this is dingle
University Cara Nakamura and this is
Game five so it's already Armageddon and
even though there were chances on both
sides but although all four games
between the two of them ended in a draw
so I don't know who won the coin toss
but if it was he car someone mentioned
in the comments that he car said in an
interview that he actually prefers black
in Armageddon as he he's faster than
most of the players so he doesn't mind
having less time if he only needs a draw
so it does make sense but I don't know
maybe didn't want to point us and then
maybe dink chose white as dink likes to
win
I guess Oh everything is possible so if
you know who won the coin toss do share
in the comments now that being said
let's check out the game dink it opens
with c4 he goes for his English weave if
I buy a car and Knight to c3 and I'm
more often than not we will have the
four Knights of the English night of six
nine of three we have nice to see six
and now g3a preparing to fianchetto the
lights worship and d5 now immediately
striking in the center and I found when
I plug in English that this setup is is
just great for black so see characters
on d5 we have night chapters on d5 and
the bishop to g2 just nicely developing
and now tonight's the b6 avoiding
further trades we have castles in the
now Bishop to e7 Hikaru also prepares
the castle we have a three and now just
Castle so this is all a very theoretical
and both of them are just blazing these
moves out or both of them no no this
stuff we have d3 and Bishop to e6 now
and the blush of the e3 for the moment
preventing the d2 points from being
developed but you're not interested in
development developing d2 point at all
obviously in this line so tonight's the
v5 now going for some trades in the
center being captures we have cappers
here and now Quinta a four and now the
rooks are connected you can start
getting your looks into the game the
idea is rooks you want to see three and
then double up on the C file bringing
the other rook over to see one we looked
at ei twice akaru he develops the rook
and now rook a to see one with the
before-mentioned plan we have a six now
you can kick away the Queen would be
five in the future if needed and rook
the c3 preparing to double up we have
Bishop to f6 and now we reach the
position that has already been reached
in a very important game in 2014 as
Sergey Karjakin had it against the
Veselin Topalov in the candidates
tournament and the game ended in a draw
after rook the c5 was played by two by a
carjacking and it seems like you should
move the rook since if efore comes it
will be a double attack here but being
shows that there is no need to do this
he just goes rook to d1 point is that
now you align the rook with the Queen
and you are indirectly defending against
any and all threats for example if you
push efore immediately then just D
captures on e4 and okay you lose the
rook but then you capture the bishop on
d5 and now again your attacking both of
these pieces and once the knight moves
you're just gonna capture here and you
will have two pieces for the rook well
the bishop prepare for the rook adapt so
after Brooke the d1 and nakamoto just
continues with Knights to d4 and now
rook the b2 defending the e2 pawn so
this is this is one of the weirder pawns
in in any line that you'll see knife
captures on f3 with Czech Bishop
captures and now Bishop captures on f3
being recaptures with the e pawn and now
okay you do have a doubled F pawn and
the isolated D pawn but it's not it's
not really a problem dings King will be
very safe on g2 now these pawns really
really defend the White King well and
you're gonna push d4 at some point
getting rid of your backwards isolated
pawn and that's just that's just you
know good chess so c6
and not allowing c7 to remain a target
after the Queen is developed and now
King to g2 just improving the position
of the King we have G sex by Hikaru in
now
Quinta efore not going for d4 right away
it of course is possible but the dink
tries to keep the tension for as long as
possible as he needs a winter to win the
match
so Bishop back to g7 now making room for
f5 if needed and now dingos for b4 so
still waiting with this d4 idea but now
Hikaru goes at five and he allows this
Quinta c4 check we have King to a trade
and only now d4 biding yes okay we have
a four by Hikaru
and now d5 further advancing the point
with captures on f3 with check and here
ding recaptures with the king looks a
bit dangerous but doesn't seem like
there's a way for you to do anything
here and the now Queen to e7 also
possible is just Bishop captures and c3
with check but with the F pawn being
pushed all the way here after Queen
captures and c3 checking g8 it could be
it could be very dangerous Bishop to h6
ideas and well yeah in a in a game where
we'll in a blitz game where you're just
playing against ding you do not want the
disposition and pretty much any anyone
would give up the exchange here for the
for the for the very strong dark square
bishop so after King captures on f3
Hikaru goes King Queen to e7 instead and
now ding just needs to continue the game
for example there are a lot of ways you
could continue the game one way you
don't want to continue is d6 d6 looks
very strong but then you just allow
black to trade off everything it seems
like it's still strong but after Queen
e4 check and now you're actually trading
of Queens so for example if Queen
captures you recapture with check and
then you're gonna grab the rook very
happily
so here you'd have to go back and then
comes Queen captures rook captures and
let's say located e8 and it would be
it's hard to imagine that this pawn will
ever go forward with both players have
having a dark square bishop so being
needing to win the game and he just
keeps the pressure he goes rook c2 c2
and now comes C captures on d5 we looked
at force on d5 by Nakamura and rook a to
d8 now and here again ding just needs to
play rook rook to D to double up on the
D file end of the game continues however
being played one move that
looks perfectly reasonable and and
normal and even good but in the end it's
a move that blunders the game so here
Dean played King to g2 he just improved
the safety of his King and okay you
still have a queen and rook on the C
file you can still double up here you
can trade you can do whatever the
problem is thing is completely lost here
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning idea for Hikaru here
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as you must be
practicing your tactics on a daily basis
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show here in this position he
Karl played b5 and it's what a move it
it frees the b7 squared for the Queen
which tempo as the White Queen and c4 is
under attacks just brilliant stuff here
ding has to move the Queen he played
Queen to d3 to keep guarding the rook
but here he Carl just played Queen to b7
attacking the pinned piece and it was in
this position unmoved 29 that Dingley
ran resigned the game and with it the
match so Hikaru gets two points being
one for reaching the Armageddon but here
there is nothing to do your rook is
under attack and it's attacked twice you
could defend it one more time but that's
that's it after Luke c5
he called adds a third attacker and
after rook e5 there's nothing you can do
having only a dark square bishop next
move whatever you play rook captures
rook and well you will be down a rook
and completely lost so really really
amazing stuff but he caught played this
like in an instant all that puzzle rush
must be really paying off for him as you
can see and yeah he wins the match and
so I don't forget that we're just gonna
check out the standings after after
round 6 day 2 there we have it in first
place he called Nakamura followed by
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano Khurana three
of them tied with 13 points
ding Liron with 12 followed by an
opponent really resolution Maxime
holograph and uh nigiri in last place
for the moment so this this means that
it's not gonna be very very intense
tomorrow one more round will still be
played before we go into playoffs but we
already have the top 4 so nakamura calls
and Caruana and ding Liron are going
into the playoffs into the knockout
stage of the tournament
and it's it's over for the rest but they
are still playing tomorrow to see who
wins how much money even if they don't
continue in the tournament so really
wild game very theoretical struggle I
mean both Bing and he called knew what
they were doing but this King to g2 move
that looked perfectly normal you know I
was that was what resulted in Indians
demise sure yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Abdul Moxie know Rajee yeah
Carsten Kurtz Steven Atkinson Chris
Antley and Martin Fisher for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational one more round and
then we go into the playoffs so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day